you boy yes you are
hey guys how's it going bill today well
the days actually over already
this vlog is pretty much the past few
weeks of what I've been doing the first
we're going to start off by making some
dinner I know you guys have seen a lot
of cooking videos here and you've seen a
lot of cooking sales and something that
I've seen a lot of my friends do make
blue apron meal this box that you see
behind me full of fresh ingredients it
comes with recipes I've seen so many
videos of people doing this and I feel
like I know and exactly what I'm getting
myself into they shift this all to you
they ship pretty much every room country
bottle becomes refrigerators if you're
not home everything new stay nice and
fresh until you get back I'm going to be
making a saffron and tomato
bucatini pasta with summer squash and
basil that sounds a super super fancy so
many ingredients for over meals you
think it will even respond from this
video and making it might be dream come
true
[Music]
a large cloth salted water cut up all
our vegetables check string we got pasta
I gotta get out of this pot they're
different sizes I did the one for two
people
[Music]
irises living here my meal and I'm
seriously incredibly impressed I hope
you guys enjoy the rest of this log
thanks much for watching which you
enjoyed this delicious liver needle up
the link in the description where the
first hundred people can get three eel
for free sorry
don't you
change is amazing oh my god I love it a
lot I love it I love it
[Applause]
humming oh my god work with whoever I
also I can't believe is on but I have a
tail
[Music]
[Applause]
I just adipose made my breakfast and
writing super late this morning heading
it to do Kathy's podcast and super
excited but first I've gotta have some
breakfast I know we're gonna have time
to make it but yet I have time to vlog
like what is my problem I have no idea
like stop vlogging eat your food get in
the car
[Music]
I can't cool I like walked it it barely
even said hi to Cathy and I just saw the
dog like I'm dying oh this is like your
little office huh this is the rocket pub
it's a Frankie the Bloggie dog look at
you though you were just the Sweden and
she is such a sweet little temperament
yeah she got her fed Mimi she peels like
oh that's how you know that's how you
know every love you like it oh oh yeah
very very room oh he was just in a bit
fitness video with me and she like
basically was a star no one cared
no one cared about me didn't work out
our new star oh my goodness yes so
congrats in the podcast
oh hey how is it health podcasting life
um podcasting life is you know at first
we weren't going to film it so I like
cool I can just go in and do it without
my hair makeup and now we're filming it
as obviously and it's just like a
filming day but it's good because I get
those super deep yeah and really talking
this is my partner are you by lighting
people
but look at the dog and love and
everything oh my goodness
see a super excited into having me on so
look yeah we just fitted
I love your setup because you do when
you show me the secret bench because I
thought a goal bench
okay should we this is behind the scenes
so you think this is like a chic couch
right you get the bench but it looks so
good I mean that's pretty much like the
master art of like set decoration when
you actually like look into what things
are but it looks so good I love it guys
you so much fun good morning so today is
an exciting day I just woke up said
Maddie his breakfast now we're going to
play a little bit Johnny baboon oh my
gosh this is actually another dog's toy
and he left it here when we were
babysitting him and his favorite toy
because he knows it's not his destiny
beta is coming out today so I have to go
upstairs do all of the updates and
download the beta you guys haven't
played much Xbox recently because of
this little guy
and then splatoon comes out tomorrow
making us will tune I gotta go post my
YouTube video we made a splatoon okay it
looks like a Nintendo suevel tunze a
golden you gotta go the video is not
going to post it's out I also need to
clean my house today but that's like the
last thing on my list to do fuel for my
body so I look at this desk all slob the
Hedberg that's actually sort of cleaned
steps for posting a YouTube video next
video some people enjoy looking at my
timeline let me give you a quick little
peek at this video it took me a long I
get it a lot about it like this just
makes my heart hurt and we cruise
through and this isn't even I mean this
took me a long time but some take me
even longer
should I get a bigger guy yeah we'll get
it maybe get a serrated knife you can
use myself oh I have little ears that's
why I keep my not as recognized upstairs
what's happening up there a woodworker
this is my first machete how do you how
do you have that happening any Michael
work but when I said serrated I didn't
mean I'll so aggressive agent
this is what I have to go through to try
to catch my dog like it's absolutely
insane that I have to put the part up on
you and he's faster than me like so
freakin bad it's unreal oh my god I'm
going to meet Jenna and Matt and Nick at
furniture store Hey look feet so that's
even dog for a walk I'm doing destiny
all day it's been so much fun whatever
you do in my office again and my guest
bedroom and doing a few little additions
here so I got a look at some furniture
come on over walk and that's what I'm to
do okay cool
be right back traffic is so terrible
they're already there and I'm going to
miss out on all the fun
what do you want the fate of Jenna I'm
not there yet because you guys didn't
give me enough heads up I'm about 28
minutes away of a really long time your
message says I'm not there yet because
you guys didn't give me enough heads-up
I'm about 28 minutes away that's a
really long time ready to send it yes
Genesis lol want to reply yeah lol your
reply says lol ready to send it yes
Dylan this is taking about an hour to
get here this is absolutely insane
insane
that was the third amount of time to be
sitting in traffic holy moly I have to
pee I can't believe we're back here
again yeah Steve Arkell early evening
came for you a new nickname I'm J dog
oh I'm getting a new nickname J or J dog
Stephanie oh nice and cute a nice
racquetball wow that's big award you
[Music]
these are my favorite we do not only
help you find the boys and maybe get
some dinner
you just find some things I'm super
excited I'd also like to get some stuff
for my outdoor patio with that forever
day okay oh the problem is there are so
many spiders and spider webs outside it
looks like they've really destroyed my
entire outdoor backyard lovely instead
oh my god awesome calorie challenge
yeah here's my Patty and my salad
those groups yeah that weird cool croc
we played a really fun game today
Brooklyn and Bailey are in the house hi
how are you
if you're worried what's on my face this
marker we did some things today we
filmed a really cool video for their
channel really said I never emoji music
yes I got a little crazy yeah it was
pretty crazy and I've got marker all
over the place it will all be explained
very very soon well thanks for coming
and hanging out and your daughter's
became to sing along gosh me Eddie here
Prince this is before and then we'll see
after we're going to get Matty a haircut
I know these are always such riveting
vlogs when we take the dogs to the
groomers Jenna do you remember Matt was
in my house and he may have had a few
too many adult beverages which time
through the most recent yeah and he
couldn't find his hat is the Hat under
there what you gonna be so excited this
is like disgusting
have a gander there why did the 30 is
intervene and why is it are the couch
I don't know you can be so excited
should we hold hostage and looks like it
like on like you know for yeah yes you
an over a gun yeah but don't you be much
cooler so
[Music]
boy give it a 50 give that a good P
Justin turn in there for you
pianos give you your toy okay you look
one for you
you're a team if you want your toy picks
to put now you lucky corncob that first
is here you have the elephant you want
what else in here what about this what
about this this is for kitty I've been
to love this one now but that was for
the kidding for you when you guys are
watching hope you guys enjoyed this vlog
this was just the past few days maybe a
week I'm not even sure I lose track when
I do vlogs that are super long like this
there's one thing I do know though I
freaking love dog I think he likes it
horn
[Music]